how you doing guys today we have 2017
Honda Pilot customer have one working
key and we're going to create another
Universal autel key fob let's get
started so the first thing we need to
create the FCC ID uh to match the same
as the original and then we can program
so you're going to go in the menu for
Universal key and you're going to look
for Honda Pilot and we're going to do
generate Universal key uh I'm going to
Speed it Forward while it's riding it
down takes about probably a
[Music]
minute and that's it you can hit
completed after you finish up writing it
down I like to go back to the main menu
and make sure that we have the U desired
frequency so I'm going to press on it
next to the antenna and we're going to
see the frequency to make sure that it's
matching all right we're going to go to
the car uh and in order to program uh
we're going to put the dungle in the OBD
right
underneath by the way if you like those
videos don't forget to like And
subscribe I always start when they is on
on position I'm going to go to
immobilizer we're going to go and look
for
[Music]
Honda um it tells me that the uh the
dungle is not connected so I'm going to
hit okay and I'm going to go to the
settings on
top and we're going to open the
VCI and make sure that it's connected to
the dle first
in order to have
communication as soon as it's connected
you can uh you can go back in the menu
and hit automatic
selection ignition is on on position so
we're going to read the V
[Music]
number we got the V number we'll hit
okay and it's going to decoded we're
going to put smart key because it's a
push start then we're going to hit push
to start
start we're going to verify all the
information and hit
yes we're going to go to hot
function uh you ask me if the if the
ignition turns on when you press twice I
wrote yes because we have a working
key we're going to do add key because I
do not want to delete all the rest and
we're going to start the
[Music]
procedure tells me if I want to to clear
all the engine codes they said there is
nothing there so I just hit
okay tell me to switch the ignition
[Music]
off place the learn key in the vehicle
and take any other keys out of the car
so I'm going to leave the original in
the car and I'm going to take the
universal one the one that it's not
programmed I'm going to take it out of
the vehicle at least 5 m away I'm going
to leave it right here and we'll keep
the programming
procedure going to hit
okay please turn the ignition switch on
without pushing the brake P pedal I'm
going to press twice on the start in
order to turn it on
[Music]
position
all of those steps it does automatically
in a hot function so we don't need to
press on anything it says programming
proceeded would you like to program next
key I'm going to say yes because I want
to program the new one he tell me to
take all the keys out so with the
ignition on I'm going to take the
original as as well and I'm going to put
it outside of the
vehicle and I'm going to press okay on
the machine after we took it
[Music]
out then it tells me to bring the new
key the unprogrammed one into the
vehicle so I'm going to take the new
Hotel
Universal and as soon as I'm sitting
inside I I like to put it next to the
ignition without pressing just next to
it and I'm going to hit
[Music]
okay programming succeeded I'm going to
hit
okay it's going to turn the ignition off
I'm going to press with the fob
itself turn on so I'm going to press
twice this is the closing of the
programming mode that's the
procedure it'd ask me if both security
lights are off I'm going to hit
[Music]
yes turn the ignition off I turned it
off turn it on again going to press
[Music]
twice
completed switch it off
and then it tells me to check all the
remotes make sure everything starts so
we're going to test it
out everything works the way it
should and we're going to try also to
start the
vehicle I'm going to test it first from
outside
[Music]
long press on the circle that's the
remote start so it's going to start the
car and long press again to turn it
off long press on the trunk in order to
par the
trunk everything works the way it should
I'm going to lock it up and check the
proximity and everything works nice and
easy guys thank you so much for watching
if don't forget to like And subscribe if
you have any questions let me know in
the comments below i' love to answer
those questions thank you
again